call of duty black ops cold war is right
around the corner so let's keep this
hype train moving and discuss
our top 10 kill streaks from the black
ops series kill streaks score streaks
it's all here
let's get into it number 10
rc xd at this point we simply can't have
a black ops game without our favorite
remote controlled companion
the rcxd is a perfect low end kill
streak that's easy
and fun to use perfect for game modes
like domination and search and destroy
the rcxd can clean up a hot spot that's
filled with enemies or
even take out a lone sniper that's been
bugging you from across the map
in black ops 3 our little buddy even got
a hover conversion known as the
hcxd when black ops originally released
in 2010
the special collector's edition came
bundled with a functioning rc xd with a
built-in camera
how cool is that
oh anyway in early 2020 we saw the rc xd
teased in warzone
by the looks of it it was being
assembled with the other half found
later in an unlocked bunker
well after we got our hands on cold
war's multiplayer we're happy to confirm
that this is indeed coming back
so get your battery packs charged and
let's go
can we cut this footage please number
nine
lightning strike task lightning
there's a reason lightning strikes are
in nearly every black ops game
they're a well-rounded low to mid-level
streak that has some
serious potential you pick three
locations to attack
and in and out they go and to be fair
the strike itself is a little too
precise and can miss targets if they
decide to move a few feet
but we all know how it feels when we see
the screen light up with hit markers and
score
on the other hand you're probably not
going to be too upset if you missed the
strike entirely
you'll get another one soon also if
memory serves these came in care
packages quite a bit
number 8 guardian let's talk defense
we're all aware of the numerous sentry
guns that black ops has offered over the
years
they're a defensive staple however most
can be destroyed pretty easily with a
good knifing a well-placed grenade or by
unloading your magazine at a weak spot
here's where guardians have the
advantage while you still have a shot at
landing a grenade or firing off some
shots
the guardian from black ops 2 and 3
microwaves you
from there you have two options keep
firing or get microwaved to death
it's annoying yes but if you need to
hold down a tight spot for a moment the
guardian is your friend stupid bots
hey also depending on the game
automated sentries don't always see
enemies right away
which sucks
number seven sam turret here's another
one for defense
sadly the surface-to-air missile turret
or sam turret
was only featured in black ops one it
was great for support players like me
whose secondary is
always a rocket the sam turret would
fire missiles to take down most airborne
kill streaks
it was one of the best defensive kill
streaks costing only four of your hard
earned kills
on top of that this thing can
accidentally kill other players
observed
nowadays we don't see the sam turret in
most black ops games
so i guess it's back to the rockets for
[Music]
me
number six carpet bomber the almighty
carpet bomber is a menacing and
unforgiving kill streak
it lays waste to anything underneath it
in a slow indestructible
boeing b-52 if he saw this thing in the
air
it was over while other gunships like
the warthog and thresher are similar
the carpet bomber in black ops 3's
bombing run aren't flashy and fast
they're slow and destructive no matter
what game mode you're playing
carpet bombers will destroy everything
in their path
including you number 5
lodestar featured only in black ops 2
the lodestar lets players take control
of the laser-guided missile system
from high in the sky unlike the ac-130s
40 millimeter cannon the lodestar's
missile system is way more forgiving
after it's fired missiles can be guided
to follow targets for improved accuracy
if enemies can manage to whip out their
small rocket in time it'll take
three of them to drop the lodestar out
of the sky
number 4 chopper gunner sometimes in
black ops
less is more this is indeed the case for
the chopper gunner in black ops
one after nine kills players were
rewarded with this show-stopping kill
streak that punished enemies below
controlling a minigun with infinite ammo
and no cooldown you have
60 seconds straight up delete enemies
[Music]
even though a smaller map is preferred i
had no trouble wasting these stupid bots
bots because no one's playing this game
anymore
if you're on xbox and want to get a game
going sometime let me know on twitter
bottom line the chopper gunner is simple
destructive
and awesome number three
stealth chopper sometimes it's nice not
to have to do all the heavy lifting
we've all been there in the middle of
battle you don't want to be interrupted
to control something like a chopper
gunner or a hind
despite how awesome it is you want to be
on the ground in control of your gun
that's where the stealth chopper comes
in this kill streak goes by a few names
including cobra
and wraith but its only goal is to do
the killing for you
since you're not the one in control
stealth choppers can take quite a bit of
extra damage and also come equipped with
flares
so sit back and watch the free kills
pile up
you earned it number 2
the swarm ah yes the elusive final kill
streak from black ops 2.
the wrath of the swarm was an
unforgettable one
if you didn't feel like a champion
calling one in you felt like an absolute
scrub getting repeatedly bombed by it
costing an astounding 1900 points this
mass of hunter killer drones lasted for
45 excruciating
circling above players these hunter
killers are much faster and more
relentless than dogs
so your best chance was to hide indoors
and take cover
be advised swarm inbound number one
attack dogs beginning before the black
ops series
treyarch introduced attack dogs in
2008's call of duty world at war
since then they've been used in one form
or another across all four black ops
games
cementing them as a powerful high-level
kill streak you call them in and they
relentlessly attack enemies for 60
seconds
personally i dig the robotic
anti-personnel sentries aka the raps
from black ops 3
all the danger of dogs without actually
harming them
listen they even growl
oh if you want to share your favorite
killstreak memories or have an idea for
another call of duty video
find me down in the comments thanks for
watching
[Music]
you